et ben nous ça c'est n pour pour
l'instant c'est déjà pas mal
bon chers
collègues chers
invités vous êtes
prêts
parfait alors d'abord euh je voudrais
excuser le président de notre commission
Jean François Rapin qui est retenu dans
son département du Pas decalais où il
reçoit euh la première ministre min
madame borne qui vient y constater
malheureusement je dirais la situation
catastrophique provoquée par les
inondations de ces derniers jours et
donc il m'a demandé de le remplacer ce
matin donc on va auditionner aujourd'hui
la Cour des comptes européennes je
rappelle que la Cour a été créée en 1977
à l'initiative du Parlement européen et
elle est devenue une institution de
l'Union
européenne en
1993 depuis lors elle assiste le
Parlement européen et et le conseil dans
l'exercice de leur fonction de contrôle
de l'exécution du budget la cour est en
effet chargée de l'audit des finanance
de l'Union
européenne à ce titre elle contribue à
améliorer la gestion financière de cette
dernière et joue le rôle de gardienne
indépendante des intérêts financiers des
citoyens de
l'Union le président de notre commission
avait eu l'occasion de se rendre au
Luxembourg au siège puisque le le le
siège de la la Cour des Comptes est au
luxembg our et non pas à Bruxelles ou à
Strasbourg avec donc son homologue de
l'Assemblée nationale à l'époque il y a
18 mois ils avaientz alors eu le plaisir
de vous rencontrer Monsieur Casala vous
qui êtes le le membre français de cet
organe parfois méconnu c'est
vrai vous êtes 27 membres comme le
nombre d'état-membres comme les
commissaires comme soit un par
état et vous employez en tout ça
représente quand même 1000 à peu près
1000000 salariés 1000 employés en tous
les cas soyez remerciés d'être présent
ici au Sénat ce matin vous êtes le
bienvenu alors la la la Cour des Comptes
est organisée en 5 chambres par domaine
de compétence trois d'entre elles sont
représenté à notre réunion ce
matin grâce à la participation à
distance de plusieurs collaborateurs de
la cour que je remercie aussi d'être
connecté avec nous par visioconférence
ils vont me le confirmer quand je vais
les appeler madame Servane de bec de
lièvre auditrice de la chambre
i pardon compétente sur l'utilisation
durable des ressources naturelles vous
êtes là madame le bec de lièvre
elle n'est pas là où elle se
cache monsieur
comment ah voilà mais je vous avez pas
vous avez pas mis votre son je vous
entends
pas je ne vous entends pas
Madame micro micro appuy sur
micro non
non je vous vois mais je ne vous entends
pas on va passer après au collègue
suivant monsieur josepp Diana qui est
auditeur principal à la chambre 4
dont vous êtes membre monsieur cas et
qui est compétente sur la réglementation
des marchés et l'économie
concurrentielle
monsieur parfaitement
parfaitement Madame Brigitte Cheffer
dont on a entendu le chien tout à
l'heure manager principal au service
juridique de la cour madame cheff vous n
entendez oui je vous entends bien
mentendez aussi ça va très bien le chien
va bien elle va bien j'espère qu'elle va
se calmer là maintenant désolé pour ça
mais c'est pas grave c'est amusant
plutôt Monsieur Christian
Stiner bonjour Snitter Snitter désolé
désolé monsieur Snitter monsieur Snitter
donc vous êtes chef de cabinet du du
membre grec de la cour monsieur Nicolaos
millionis qui siège à la Chambre 1 on
est d'accord bonjour je suis avec ma
collègue dans le même bureau maintenant
le son passe et vous pouvez nous
contacter par ce profil j'ai eu aussi
parfit et et enfin Monsieur Frédéric
sobelet donc auditeur confirmé à la
chambre 3 qui est compétente pour
l'action extérieure la sécurité et la
justice monsieur sobelet vous êtes
là monsieur soblet n'est pas là pour
l'instant en tous les cas nous vous
sommes reconnaissant ici au Sénat de
vous être mobilisé en si grand nombre
euh il est vrai que nous sommes
particulièrement intéressé par plusieurs
euh de nombreux et excellents documents
qu'a publié la cour nous souhaiter
comment Monsieur Noblet est là oui
est-ce que monsieur sobet bonjour
monsieur soblet bonjour c'est bon on
vous entends ah super merci parfait donc
je disais que nous aimer nous
souhaiterions notamment évoquer
aujourd'hui le rapport annuel évidemment
publié par la cour mais aussi ses
publications relatives à la gouvernance
économique à la
cybersécurité aux éoliennes et à
l'éthique que nous aborderons dans cet
ordre dans cet ordre et sur lesquels nos
rapporteurs compétents vous
interrogeront alors l'idée c'est de de
consacrer 20 minutes environ à chaque
sujet pour tenir en 2 heur notre réunion
comme prévue on va essayer de tenir le
timing
ok
alors je suggère que nous commencions
par évoquer évidemment le le rapport
annuel de la Cour relatif à l'exécution
du budget de l'Union
européenne il nous a alerté car la cour
y rend une opinion défavorable sur la
légalité et la régularité des dépenses
budgétaires
elle justifie cette opinion défavorable
au regard de la forte augmentation des
erreurs dans les dépenses financées par
le budget de l'Union en 2022
elle estime le taux d'erreur à 4,2 % ce
qui est significatif et même à 6 % pour
les dépenses fondées sur des
remboursements ces éléments sont
particulièrement
préoccupants à l'heure où la Commission
propose de revoir à mi-parcours le cadre
financier pluriannuel pour le majoré de
80 milliards
d'euros nous avons aussi relevé que la
moitié des opérations examinées par la
cour au titre de l'instrument de
voisinage de coopération au
développement et de coopération
internationale appelé i B C D C Europe
dans le monde
comportait des erreurs ceci nous souciit
particulièrement sachant que la
Palestine est le 4ème bénéficiaire de
cet instrument avec 100 millions 120
millions d'euros en
2022 si nous devons continuer à soutenir
les Palestiniens nous devons aussi
absolument renforcer le contrôle sur
l'usage des fonds puisqu'elle n'a pas de
pouvoir d'investigation la cour a-t-elle
signalé ces cas de fraude et de
corruption potentiel à l'Office européen
de de lutte antifraude ou au Parquet
européen
un certain nombre de questions mais il y
en aura
d'autres monsieur Casala je vous cède la
parole pour un propos liminire je vous
en
prie merci merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs Mesdames et
Messieurs Je j'ai
l'honneur pour la première fois depuis
ma ma nomination à la Cour des comptes
européennes venant de la la Cour des
comptes françaises où j'ai eu le plaisir
de travailler un peu
avec Christine Lavarde de vous présenter
les constats et les principaux messages
du rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes
européennes relatif à l'exercice
2022 je vous remerci beaucoup de cette
occasion que vous me fournissez de
rendre ainsi compte des travaux de la
cour du moins de leur principal
composantes en en en homme jour si je
puis dire car pratiquement 50 % de nos
ressources sont affectés à ce qui est un
sujet de préoccupation d'ailleurs pour
nous à la confection de ce rapport
annuel alors je remercie comme vous
l'avez fait je m'associe au remerciement
que vous avez fait à la l'encontre à
l'égard de de des collaborateurs de la
cour qui se sont mobilisés ce matin je
n'ai pas la science infuse sur tous les
sujets le mandat de la Cour est vaste
j'y reviendrai et comme vous l'avez
mentionné moi je suis donc à la chambre
4 euh qui s'occupe de ce que vous avez
indiqué donc marché
intervention intervention économique de
l'Union européenne mais aussi les
institutions financières
euh euroeopéenne eu
et sur un certain nombre de de de sujets
que dans la préparation de cette
audition
euh qui ont été évoquées
euh
mais les collaborateurs de la cour en
savent beaucoup plus que moi et seront
prêt à répondre à vos questions comme je
le suis moi-même pour la partie que je
connais un petit peu mieux je complète
un petit peu ce que vous avez dit je
crois que l'occasion est bonne sur la
Cour elle-même avant d'aborder la
question du rapport annuel euh vous avez
dit vous avez dit l'essentiel
euh j'y ajouterai le fait que la Cour
contrôle l'ensemble des dépenses et des
recettes
de l'Union
européenne c'est-à-dire ainsi que les
personnes et les organisations qui gèent
des fonds de l'Union européenne donc
dans un premier temps c'est
effectivement la commission mais aussi
le Conseil le Parlement euh le comités
économique et social enfin les
différents comités comités des régions
qui ont été mis en
place au niveau des des institutions
européennes la Cour de justice euh et
les institutions associées et euh je le
mentionne parce que j'en suis chargé les
agences qui sont une euh une catégorie
qui a fleurri au cours des dernières
années est-ce la nécessité des problèmes
est-ce la soif de siège je ne sais pas
c'est quelque chose qui mériterait
d'être analysé mais euh ça s'est
multiplié euh au cours des dernières
années nous le faisons au moyen de
contrôle aléatoir dans les institutions
européennes bon principalement la
commission mais pas seulement comme j'ai
indiqué les États-membres et tout autre
pays recevant des aides de l'Union
européenne au titre de la coopération de
l'aide au développement et cetera alors
à la différence je crois que c'est
important de le mentionner à la
différence de son homologue française
mais à l'image de la plupart des
institutions supérieures de contrôle de
finances
publiques la Cour des comptes
européennne ne dispose pas de
compétences juridictionnell il y a pas
de il y a pas de responsabilité
personnelle et pécunière des des
comptables qui viendrait à être mise en
cause devant la la Cour des comptes
européennes mais c'est quand même une
cour car l'appellation est est est est
générique et c'est ainsi qu'elle figure
notamment dans les traités celui de
Maastricht qui l'a élevé au rang
d'institution
euh alors qu'elle existait déjà depuis
une une vingtaine d'années dans un
statut euh dans un statut moins euh
moins solennel
[Musique]
euh pour vous donner une idée de ce que
nous a dit
réellement j'ai sur une des diapos la
suivante je pense fait figurer c'est la
3 là c'est la de
voilà un un petit graphique qui est
assez inspiré d'ailleurs de ce qu'un de
vos anciens collègues également membres
du Parlement européen qui s'était
beaucoup intéressé à à ces questions
monsieur artui pour ne pas le nommer
avait à
l'époque conçu en parlant de galaxie
financière de l'Union européenne
alors de manière plus plus moins moins
imagée nous parlons de paysage financier
c'est plus poli vis-à-vis des
institutions mais ça reste quand même
assez complexe comme vous pouvez le le
voir c'est différentes entités ces
différentes personnes morales ces
différents budgets don certains sont
d'ailleurs des fonds extra buudgétaires
c'est pour ça qu'il ne figurent pas dans
la grande le grand oval du milieu étant
sujet à des modalités un peu trop
diverses nous l'avons évoqué dans un
rapport dont j'étais dont j'étais le le
le le le rapporteur récemment euh et
parfois un peu un peu un peu
contradictoire globalement nous auditons
tout ce qui se trouve dans les cercles
bleus et rouges avec des compétences un
petit peu diverses on y reviendra si
vous voulez mais enfin c'est c'est pour
euh évoquer à ce stade malgré tout la la
complexité de notre tâche euh même si
encore une fois notre
compétence est définie de manière très
générale par les traités diapo suivante
s'il vous plaît la cour consigne ses
constats et ses recommandations dans des
rapports d'audit des rapports annuels
donc je vais présenter celui sur
l'exercice 2022 et des rapports spéciaux
que nous appelons ainsi ces derniers
étant conc étant consacrés à No de
performance à peu près l'équivalent des
rapports de la Cour des comptes
françaises que vous avez l'habitude et
vos collèg allement de de lire et et et
et et sur lesquelles il est fréquent ça
m'est arrivé de procéder à des auditions
dans cette enceinte après examen de ces
rapports qui sont présentés bien sûr au
Conseil et à au Parlement il est
important vous l'avez fait monsieur le
Président de de bien dire que nous
sommes également redevables vis-à-vis du
conseil et du Parlement même si c'est
vrai le Parlement a un intérêt tout
particulier pour nos pour nos activités
euh le Parlement prend des résolutions
et notamment sur le rapport annuel c'est
la base de la décision qu'il est amené à
prendre dans le cadre de la procédure de
décharge de la Commission et des autres
institutions européennes chargées de la
gestion d'un budget alors une chose qui
nous différencie aussi de la Cour des
comptes français c'est que nous publions
des avis euh soit obligatoire soit
facultatif nous pouvons nous saisir
nous-mêm et récemment nous l'avons fait
j'y reviendrai si vous voulez sur soit
des actes législatifs préparatoires euh
soit des questions plus générales au
moyen de de travaux qui sont pas des
travaux d'audit à pour parler mais
plutôt des travaux de de compilation et
de de
synthèse de rapports ou de documents
déjà existants
euh on appelle ça des review dans le
langage anglaxon de la cour c'est mal
traduit en français par revue ça c'est
pas le bon mot mais euh c'est une une
activité qui qui existe
également alors ce qu'il est important
par rapport à ce que je vais vous dire
sur le budget 2022 de noter c'est que
depuis le traité de Maastricht le mandat
de la Cour a été étendu pour couvrir non
seulement ce qu'elle faisait
classiquement et avant la cour française
qui ne le fait que depuis la LOLF euh à
savoir la certification proprement dit
des comptes comme un commissaire aux
comptes certifie les comptes d'une d'une
entreprise mais nous sommes aussi
appelés euh à fournir une déclaration
d'assurance sur la légalité et la
régularité des opérations recettes et
paiements sous-jacentes euh à
l'exécution du budget quand un
commissaire au compte certifier un
compte euh il se prononce pas sur la
régularité euh
la légalité des opérations d'appel
d'offre par exemple il se content de
vérifier que il y a bien eu un marché de
passé et que les montants sont bien dans
le rapport
euh l'important c'est Infiné d'avoir une
image financière correcte de l'activité
de l'entité en cause mais là ce qu'on
nous a demandé en plus mission
impossible en réalité compte tenu du
nombre de transaction et la cour
française est dans la même situation
d'ailleurs c'est de fournir une opinion
sur la légalité et la régularité de
chaque transaction alors alors comp tenu
euh des dizaines de milliers de
transactions ça reste moins que le
budget français hein mais ça est quand
même beaucoup
euh par lesquels le budget de l'Union
européenne s'exécute c'est évidemment
impossible on serait encore aujourd'hui
sur le budget je sais pas moi
2000 alors qu'on nous demande de fournir
un rapport annuel
donc nous procédons selon l'application
des normes classiques d'audit qu'on a
transféré à cet examen de la régularité
en portant une appréciation sur les
dispositifs de gestion et de contrôle
interne des entités contrôlées qui sont
censés garantir en premier lieu la
légalité et la régularité des recettes
et des
dépenses excusez-moi et nous les
complétons par des sondages
euh sur ces opérations de recettes et de
dépenses jusqu'éventuellement s'agissant
des dépenses jusqu'au bénéficiaire final
on peut aller dans une ferme aufin fond
des Pouilles vérifier si les surfaces
qui ont été déclarées au titre de la
politique agricole commune étai bien
mesuré alors maintenant on le fait avec
des satellites d'ailleurs c'est c'est
c'est c'est plus c'est plus c'est plus
pratique ce travail nous permet de
présenter des niveaux d'erreur estimés
vous en avez mentionné monsieur le
Président le taux d'erreur le fameux
taux d'erreur pour les principaux
domaines d'intervention de l'Union
européenne ainsi que pour le budget dans
son ensemble à ce stade et nous ne le
faisons pas et nous n'envisageons pas de
les faire nous ne présentons pas de taux
d'erreur par pays diapo suivante s'il
vous plaît quels sont les principaux
enseignement de notre rapport annuel
2022 quelques chiffres pour
commencer euh pendant la période
couverte par le cadre financier
pluriannuel 2021-2027 et à laquelle se
rattache ce budget 2022 les montants
devant-être contrôlés par la Cour ont
considérablement augmenté
par rapport au cadre financier
pluriannuel précédent alors au titre
budgétaire
strictoous pendant cette période l'Union
européenne est appelée à dépenser 1800
milliards d'euros ce qui englobe non
seulement le cadre financier pluannuel
de 1100 milliards d'euros c'est des
chiffres que vous connaissez sûrement
mais
également jusqu'à 750 milliards d'euros
au titre de l'instrument de relance post
covid le fameux programme generation eu
Ngu le budget annuel le budget 2022
s'élevé lui à 170 milliards d'euros en
crédit de paiement dont 167 ont été
consommés s' rajoute des paiements
supplémentaires notamment précisément
des subvention au titre du programme Ngu
pour atteindre au total pourre un total
de paiement de 243 milliards d'euros
audité par la Cour pour ce qui est des
comptes proprement dit notre travail de
commissaire aux comptes notre
certification de l'Union européenne
toute institution confondue nous
concluons comme les années précédentes
qu'il présente une image fidèle de la
situation financière nous avons par
conséquent émis une opération une une
opinion favorable sur leur
fiabilité les recettes budgétaires se
sont élevées à 245 milliards
d'euros et nous avons rendu ici aussi
une fois de plus une opinion favorable
sur leur légalité et leur urité alors le
IC c'est les dépenses euh le paquet
budgétaire à long terme de l'Union
européenne à la fois cadre financier
pluriannuel ainsi que next generation
eu les fonds de Next Generation euu vont
à hauteur de plus de 80 % à ce qu'on
appelle en français la facilité pour la
reprise et la résilience la FRR en
anglais c'est
RRF qui procède d'un modèle de mise en
œuvre différent de celui des fonds
européens classiques c'est pourquoi nous
avons émis deux opinions distinctes sur
les dépenses une sur les dépenses
classique de l'Union européenne fonds
structurel politique agricole commune
aide au développement tout ce que vous
le voudrez et fonctionnement tout
simplement d'ailleurs et l'autre pour la
facilité pour la reprise dans la mesure
je reviendrai si vous voulez où nous ne
sommes pas en mesure pour ce deuxè cette
deuxième composante pour des raisons de
principe et des raisons de
méthodologiques de définir un de
d'évaluer un taux d'erreur euh dans les
mêmes termes que nous le faisons pour
les dépenses classiques alors en ce qui
concerne ces dernières et sur la base de
notre échantillon représentatif de 768
transaction nous avons observé une
augmentation vous l'avez mentionné du
taux d'erreur globale qui est passé de 3
% en 2021 il était déjà au-dessus de ce
que nous considérons comme un seuil de
matérialité ou de signification qui est
2 %
à 4,2 % en 2022 euh en 2020 c'était déjà
2,7 % donc c'est la 4e année consécutive
que nous émettons une épinion
défavorable pour dépassement du seuil de
matérialité des irrégularités
euh alors on peut rentrer effectivement
un petit peu plus dans le détail je vous
propose pas de le faire en raison du
temps àoué mais nous avons également des
taux d'erreur au niveau de des
différentes catégories de dépenses d'une
part ce que nous considérons comme des
dépenses à haut risque pour différentes
raisons comptenu de leur nature
notamment les
remboursements les procédures
partièrement complexes ou les procédures
nouvelles qui n'ont pas qui n'ont pas
été rodés c'est quand même 66 % du
budget et nous estimons le taux d'erreur
à 6 % contre 4,7 % l'année l'année
dernière pour les dépenses à risque
moindre
euh alors pardon ces dépenses à haut
risque se subdivise elle-même entre les
différentses têtes de chapitre
budgétaires la cohésion les fonds de
cohésion sont le
principal domaine de risque on comprend
pourquoi compte tenu de la nature des
bénéficiaires qui sont pas forcément des
des des spécialistes de la comptabilité
ou du droit budgétaire ou des marchés
euh et des raisons intrinsèquesant la
complexité des procédures que j'évoqué à
l'instant mais nous trouvons également
ces dépenses à haut risque dans les
têtes de chapitre marché unique
migration sécurité
euh et voisinage qui est assez normal
pour les dépenses exécutées dans des
pays-tiers parfois un peu compliqué
notamment en matière d'aide au
développement pour les dépenses à faible
risque ben là elle ell pent bien leur
nom puisque nous avons pu constater que
euh le taux d'erreur resta en desessà du
seuil de matérialité de 2
% ce sont les dépenses dit de guichet
dépenses automatiques comme les aides
directes aux agriculteurs les bourses
Erasmus en faveur des étudiants et
cetera et cetera et bien sûr les
dépenses administratives proprement
dites de la des institutions européennes
qui représentent une part évidemment non
négligeable du budget mais que nous
considérons comme totalement bordé le
tau d'erreur est quasi quasi nul l ce
qu'il est concerne
euh nous avons été amenés à faire
différents
constats
euh s'agissant des des des des des des
rubriques que j'aiévoqué pour la
cohésion comme je disais on passe de à
un taux d'erreur de 6,4 % c'est un bon
de 80 % par rapport à l'année précédente
alors évidemment vous l'avez dit
vous-même c'est préoccupant
euh non seulement pour la politique de
cohésion elle-même mais aussi à cause
d'implication potentiell pour d'autres
composantes du budget de l'Union et
notamment la facilité pour la relance et
la résilience dont les projets
d'investissement fonctionnent d'une
manière similaire ou très proche
euh du modèle des dépenses de cohésion
alors
euh soyons clair et pour lever toute
ambiguité je pense que pour vous ça
n'est pas une une découverte mais ça
peut l'être pour
euh pour certains taux d'erreur ne
signifie pas fraude et corruption taux
d'erreur ça veut dire irrégularité alors
irrégularité ça peut être des erreurs
d'imputation ça peut être
des des
dépenses le remboursement de coût qui
n'était pas inéligible mais pour des
raisons de complexité d'ambiguité ou de
négligence ou d'ignorance tout
simplement d'incompéten des
bénéficiaires finaux ou des infractions
aux règles des marchés mais là aussi
pour des
raisons qui sont pas nécessairement
excusables mais qui peuvent être
compréhensibles l'urgence une urgence
une urgence prétendue mais qui n'est pas
avéré ça veut pas forcément dire que on
a fait du favoritisme ou de la
corruption alors il peut y avoir ce
genre de cas ça ça existe et d'ailleurs
je crois pas l'avoir mentionné dans mon
exposé mais nous avons signalé si je ne
m'ab use par rapport à 768 transactions
c'est quand même pas énorme énorme 16
cas de fraude potentielle euh à l'OLAF
et au l'office de lutte antifraude et au
procureur européen c'est à peu près dans
la fourchette de ce que nous nous nous
nous signalons chaque chaque année aux
organismes compétents
euh donc contrairement à ce que certains
des promoteurs de cette idée de euh
déclaration d'assurance défendé il y a
maintenant une une vingtaine d'années
euh l'exécution du budget européen c'est
pas un foyer euh de fraude et de
corruption il y en a c'est vrai il y a
des risques potentiels non négligeable
j'y reviendrai sur les fonds euh au
titre des fonds postcovid mais euh ça
n'est pas comme ça que je caractériserai
les principaux éléments qui euh
composent le le taux d'erreur
euh alors en revanche un autre souci
pour le la cohésion comme vous le savez
nous nous appuyons beaucoup sur les
travaux de contrôle des
États-membres qui ont leur leur
dispositifs de contrôle qui répondent
aux normes qui sont édictées par la
réglementation
applicable alors en France il y avait
dans le temps le la commission de et la
commission interministérielle de de
vérification je pense que ça existe
toujours c'est elle qui coordonne
l'ensemble des audits qui sont faits sur
des audits internes qui sont faits sur
les fonds européens
or en en revoyant ces en révisant ces
dossiers nous avons constaté que pour
plus de 60 % les dossiers de l'ensemble
pour l'ensemble des États-membres les
dossiers constitués par ces
autorités présenté à tort un niveau
d'erreur inférieur au seuil de 2 % euh
qui est celui que nous retenons
euh plus de 60 % des dossiers ça
commence à faire beaucoup surtout quand
cette proportion alors c'est peut-être
lié à notre méthodologie mais je crois
pas en tout cas pas exclusivement cette
proportion n'était que de 39 % en 2021
donc il y a
une
préoccupation sur la qualité des
contrôles auquel procèdent les
États-membres euh sur l'exécution des
euh dépenses et ça révèle certaines
lacunes auxquel il nous paraît important
de devoir remédier
euh je passe sur les autres rubriques
agriculture marché innovation on y
reviendra si vous le souhaitez
[Musique]
euh voilà dans dans les grandes lignes
les résultats de nos travaux liés à la
conformité des des dépenses
budgétaire 2022 euh il montre donc le
niveau d'erreur estimative globale
concernant ces dépenses s'inscrit en
hausse particulièrement encore une fois
dans le domaine de la cohésion qui
représente quand même 40 % du montant
total des dépenses sur cette exercice
j'ajoute une chose c'est qu'une partie
des dépenses en cause correspond à des
que de à des que de de
de de commète si je puux dire de du
cadre financier précédent euh comme vous
savez il y a toujours un risque de
désengagement
euh des des fonds européens et il est
probable qu'il y a un effet
d'accélération dans la consommation de
ces crédits qui fait que les
bénéficiaires ou les autorités de
gestion sont moins sensible à la
nécessité de respecter les règles ou
sont pressés d'absorber les fonds et
manifeste moins de Zè dans le respect
des rgles c'est un autre possible
facteur explicatif de cette augmentation
euh prè occupante encore une fois du
taux d'erreur
euh euh diapo suivante s'il vous plaît
un mot sur l'opinion séparée concernant
les dépenses de la facilité pour la
reprise et la résilience nous avons
l'occurrence formuler une opinion avec
réserve
euh alors pourquoi une opinion séparée
comme je disais le modèle de mise en
œuvre de ce fond diffère de celui des
dépenses budgétaires de l'Union
européenne euh au titre du cadre
financier
pluriannuel d'abord bon c'est un
instrument temporaire c'est comme ça
qu'il a été conçu euh et également il
était conçu pour réagir rapidement à une
situation de crise
euh en à ce stade 11 États-membres ont
reçu en 2022 13 paiements de subvention
d'une valeur totale 2022 étant la 2e
année de mise en œuvre de euh de cette
facilité en 2021 seul un État membre
avait reçu
euh une un paiement c'était l'Espagne en
2022 11 États-membres ont reçu 13
paiments de subvention d'une valeur
totale de 47 milliards nous avons
examiné la
quasi-ttalité des indicateurs justifiant
le versement de ces subventions
c'est-à-dire comme vous le savez d'une
part ce qu'on appelle les jalons euh qui
correspondent aux étapes de mise en
œuvre des réformes structurelles en
principe que cette facilité est censée
financer et d'autre part alors nous en
avons vérifié
274 et d'autre part les cibles qui là
correspondent aux étapes de réalisation
des investissements euh en l'occurrence
37 en 2022 que cette facilité est
également censée financé alors ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que
euh il s'agit d'un instrument d'urgence
c'est comme ça que ça a été présenté et
comme ça que ça a été conçu mais
toujours est-il qu'en septembre
2023 5 pays Irlande Hongrie Pays-Bas
Pologne
et suède n'ont toujours pas reçu de
paiement tandis que quatre autres
Allemagne Belgique Finlande et Estonie
n'ont reçu que des préfinancements donc
des sommes forfaitaires qui sont
pensé préfinancer sans sans rapport avec
la réalisation de de jalon proprement
dit ou de ou de cible les
opérations retenues au titre des plans
nationaux de de reprise et de résilience
euh alors après avoir examiné ces jalons
et ces cibles nous avons conclu que 15
de ces jalons et cibles présentai des
problèmes de régularité ces problèmes
tenaient soit au fait que c'estes où ces
cibles n'avaient pas été atteint de
manière satisfaisante alors un exemple
de jalon non atteint de manière
satisfaisante ça concerne en
l'occurrence la Grèce quand une réforme
est censée se décomposer en plusieurs
sous-réformes correspondant chacune par
exemple à un décret d'application d'une
loi qui aurait été
la la mre des réformes en l'occurence
euh les Grecs nous avaient dit je sais
plus quelle réforme il s'agissait marché
du travail ou quelque chose comme ça euh
il y aura 15 décrets d'application bah
on constate qu'on a libéré les fonds
alors qu'il y avait toujours trois
décrets d'application qui rester pendant
exemple type de réforme euh de jalon non
atteint de manière satisfaisante alors
ça peut être aussi les conditions
d'éligibilité comme vous le savez euh
les fonds les subventions à ce titre
était rétroactif puisqu'il permettait de
couvrir une partie des dépenses qui
avaient été exposées par certains états
la quasi totalité en fait avant
l'adoption du programme next generation
eu c'est ça a été le cas de la France
avec le plan le plan le plan le plan
d'urgence
euh on a trouvé un certain nombre
de de jalon qui correspondaiit enfin de
dépenses qui correspondaient à des
versements antérieurs encore antérieure
à cette date déjà déjà antérieure à à la
date d'adoption du programme juu donc il
est clair que c ces dépenses n'avaient
pas à être financé par le la facilité de
reprise et de résilience
euh nos travaux nous ont permis par
ailleurs de relever des faiblesses dans
le système de de contrôle de la facilité
alors ces faiblesses sont inhérantes
parce que
comme vous le savez
euh les opérations qui sont financées
par la facilité de la résilience doivent
respecter les critères de l'égalité des
dépenses de l'Union européenne que ce
soit en terme de marché de
réglementation des marchés ou en terme
d'aide d'État par exemple
or la Commission considère que c'est aux
États-membres de faire ses travails de
faire ce travail et comme on peut s'en
douter je j'en parlais tout à l'heure à
propos de des dépenses
classiques le la qualité de ce
travail demeure à être démontré nous
n'avons pas à l'URE actuel réellement
les moyens de vérifier que ces clauses
de régularité sont bien respecté donc et
nous l'avons dit dans un des premiers
audits que nous avons réalisé un audit
de système en l'occurrence où il
s'agissait de de tester euh la
pertinence des procédures qui avaient
été mise en place
euh lors de l'adoption du plan notamment
sur le contrôle le contrôle des des
opérations financées au titre du plan et
nous avons de manière très explicite
dénoncé ces lacunes donc sur la base de
ces considérations qualitatives et
quantitatives nous avons émis une
opinion avec réserve sur les dépenses au
titre de la facilité pour l'exercice
2022 euh comme je le dis nous ne sommes
pas en mesure et ne serons probablement
jamais en mesure de calculer un taux
d'erreur ça me paraît d'ailleurs
préférable car ce serait euh un calcul
assez artificiel
euh comparé à ce que l'on fait pour les
dépenses budgétaires classiques je
souhaite aussi attirer votre attention
sur le fait que nos travaux d'audit ont
mis en évidence l'existence de jalons ou
de ciblees dont la définition n'était
pas claire en soi si bien qu'il est
difficile de déterminer s'ils sont
vraiment vraiment atteints
euh et la régularité bon ben comme je le
disait c'est un c'est un défi constant
qui euh qui qui qui qui qui qui pose un
un problème compenu de
euh euh de euh la difficulté de
contrôler la manière dont les états
vérifient à leur niveau cette régularité
et cette légalité euh dans la situation
actuelle seulement 35 % des fonds ont
été déboursés 33 % pour la France et le
taux de décaissement n'est que de 24 %
si l'on tient compte également de la
partie prêt vous savez que cette
facilité est aussi déboursée via des des
prêts et nous ne sommes donc pas en
mesure c'est c'est c'est très
compréhensible de pouvoir aujourd'hui
procéder à une évaluation globale de la
facilité nous avons l'ambition de le
faire à terme pas trop lointain mais ça
ne sera qu'en combinant les résultats de
ces travaux
annuels de nos audits de performance que
nous sommes en cours de réalisation
euh que nous pourrons procéder à cette
évaluation globale et porter une opinion
d'ensemble sur ce programme quand même
très très novateur qui a été euh next
generation eu et en particulier la
facilité pour la reprise et euh la
résilience
euh alors j'ajoute que euh les dépenses
sont également un coût
euh comme vous le savez ce fond est
financé par emprunt j' j'arrive à la
conclusion euh ce fond est financé par
emprunt contracté par l'Union européenne
sur les marchés principalement des
obligations de long terme garanties par
le budget de l'Union ces emprunts
servent à financer essentiellement next
generation mais pas seulement également
l'assistance financière aux états-
membres et aux paystiers or la dette de
l'Union européenne a augmenté de manière
significative en 2022 pour atteindre 344
milliards d'euros contre
277 237 pardon en 2021 c'est c'est
essentiellement le fait du programme Ngu
bien bien sûr
euh et euh le remboursement de cette
dette euh doit euh de celle contracté au
titre de Ngu doit débuter en 2028
s'achev à euh la fin de 2058 autrement
dit il incomberra à la prochaine
génération de rembourser cette dette et
euh comme vous le savez sans doute la
question des ressources additionnelles
euh nécessaires pour assurer ce
remboursement reste ouverte alors il y a
deux facteurs qui interviennent il y a
d'une part ce que les États-membres qui
ont bénéficié de prêt seront
capable de rembourser ou non et dans
quelle mesure ceci aura une une
influence éventuelle sur leur propre
endettement c'est souvent des États qui
sont déjà endettés qui ont eu recours au
près de
Ngu d'autres part la question des
ressources additionnelles vous savez
qu'il y a des discussions en cours sur
des ressources
inelle l'une qui a abouti sur la taxe
sur les déchets plastiques mais
clairement l'évaluation qui est faite de
ces ressources additionnelles n'est pas
suffisante
pour pour pour financer le coût de de
ces emprunts coût qui risque donc
d'augmenter si l'Union européenne est
appelée ça n'est pas le cas pour
l'instant mais est appelé à refinancer
cette dette comme ses États-membres le
fond en recourant à l'emprunt à nouveau
compte tenu de la situation des taux
actuels ça n'est pas une perspective
forcément très souriante euh j'aurais pu
vous dire quelques mots sur l'Ukraine
mais je crois qu'il vaut mieux le
réserver à la suite de notre discussion
et je conclurai simplement en d'abord
vous appelant peut-être si euh vous avez
le temps à jeter un coup d'œil sur non
pas sur notre rapport qui est quand même
assez volumineux mais sur sur la
synthèse qui pour on être moi-même
client je trouve pas mal faite qui
s'appelle audit en bref et dont en
principe j'espère que les services de la
cour vous ont fourni il y a quelques
semaines un exemplaire c'est l'audit de
l'Union européenne EN BREF et je dirais
qu'il est clair que le budget de l'Union
s'inscrit dans un contexte toujours plus
vaste toujours plus complexe vous avez
mentionner les demandes supplémentaires
de la Commission au titre du budget 2024
euh aujourd'hui je me suis contenté de
soulever certains points dans le but de
démontrer que si de nombreux éléments
fonctionnent bien il y a pas lieu de
d'être
catastrophiste certaines difficultés
importantes subsistent et euh au titre
de difficultés qui fonctionne bien
d'ailleurs je suis être votre
disposition bien sûr pour répondre à
votre question comme
indiqué nous avons été informé de
l'intérêt que vous portiez à d'autres à
d'autres sujets sur lesquels je peux
pour partir répondre mais sur
d'autres j'appellerai au secours les
collaborateurs de la cour qui sont en
ligne pour compléter mes propos si
besoin est et je vous remercie de votre
attention merci beaucoup monsieur Casala
je vais tout de suite passer la parole à
à nos collègues qui sont rapporteurs sur
ce sujet Christine et et Florence
Christine tu peux tu peuxider oui merci
alors Monsieur Casala désolé parce que
je vais vous interroger peut-être sur un
sujet que vous Avaz moins évoqué qui est
le dernier rapport enfin ou en tout cas
un des derniers rapports de la Cour des
comptes européennes celui sur la gouver
l'évolution de la gouvernance
économique de l'Union européenne
euh notamment parce que enfin moi je
peux constater en tant que membre de la
commission des finances aussi ici au
Sénat que les États-membres envoi chaque
année dans le cadre du semestre européen
un certain nombre de de documents qui
font font l'objet d'une analyse par la
Commission européenne d'un rapport dont
on peut parfois se demander si la
Commission européenne va jusqu'au bout
de ce qu'elle pourrait dire notamment
sur les perspectives de de redressement
des finances publiques d'un certain
nombre d'états-membres et je ne voudrais
pas viser le nôtre en particulier et
donc je je me pose la question euh si
finalement la Commission est vraiment
totalement impartiale quand elle regarde
euh les PNR les pestables des
États-membres parce qu'en fait elle sait
que par ailleurs elle va devoir discuter
avec eux sur d'autres sujets d'autres
évolutions de la réglementation pour
faire adopter des directives et autres
et estce qui vous semblerait pas euh
plus plus judicieux euh qu'à l'instar de
ce qui est fait par exemple chez nous où
c'est euh la Cour des comptes qui émet
des avis via au Conseil des finances
publiques euh sur les différents
documents budgétaires que ce soit la
Cour des comptes européennes qui regarde
les documents transmis transmis par les
par les
États-membres et sur toujours sur sur ce
sujet d'évolution de la gouvernance
comment est-ce que vous vous considérez
euh les différentes pistes qui sont
évoquées notamment ne plus discuter de
de de sol de public mais de s'intéresser
vraiment à la trajectoire des dépenses
ce qui est un objet qui du coup occulte
les nouvelles recettes qu'on peut créer
mais vraiment s'intéresser sur la
soutenabilité et la trajectoire des
dépens et comment est-ce que vous vous
percevez les négociations à venir
sachant qu'on sait tous que aujourd'hui
l'Union européenne est quand même
fracturé entre deux blocs de pays les
frugos pour faire simple qui ont une
dette assez faible et puis les pays
dispendieux même si on on observe que la
trajectoire de certains pays qui étaient
très mauvais c'est considérablement
augmenté notamment si je pense au
Portugal à la Grèce et à
l'Irlande Gazala je vous en
prie merci beaucoup alors madame la
sénatrice chère
Christine ça cette question me dérange
pas du tout alors d'abord je ne l'ai pas
évoqué dans mon propos parce que ça n'en
était pas le
sujet le sujet c'était le l'exécution du
budget 2022
euh et autre chose
et le budget de l'Union européenne autre
chose sont les budgets des États-membres
et notamment la question de la
gouvernance économique alors mais ça ne
me gêne pas du tout parce que le rapport
que vous avez que vous avez mentionné
j'en étais le rapporteur
donc je me sens relativement à l'aise
sur pas pas sur toutes les questions
j'yeviendrai mais en tout cas sur le
rapport lui-même euh d'autant plus que
et je je je je je souhaitais le
mentionner mais j'ai oublié participe
également à cette séance le le principal
maître d'œuvre de ce de ce
rapport josepp Dana qui est qui est en
ligne avec nous et qui qui viendra
compléter mon propos si si besoin est et
je mentionne également mon chef de
cabinet dir Powells qui m'assiste
m'assiste en permanence
alors nous avons effectivement
rendu a maintenant nous l'avons publié
la semaine dernière en fait
euh un rapport alors qui rentre dans la
catégorie que j'évoqué dans mon propos
liminaire c'est pas un rapport d'audit
il av y a rien à auditer en
l'occurrence c'était c'est une revue ou
une
analyse qui se proposait de voir dans
quelle mesure les propositions fait par
la
commission alors elle remonte maintenant
à à avril si je ne si je ne si je les
dates bien en tête les propositions
faites par la commission pour répondre à
la commande de proposer une réforme du
système de gouvernance économique d'ici
le 31 déc en vue d'une adoption pour le
31 décembre 2023 je suis pas sûr que ça
on y arrivera mais c'est une autre
question
euh si ces
propositions tenez compte des
observations que nous avions pu
faire des rapports qui
eux étaient parfois des rapports d'audit
parfois des revues sur les différents
sujets tenants à l'activité de la
Commission en matière de
euh
de gouvernance économique et de pardonne
cet anglicisme de
monitorage de l'activité des
États-membres en la matière de respect
des
critères budgétaires politique de
politique budgétaire en général bien
euh ceci pour
éviter de tomber dans l'écueil et et et
de ce point de vue-là j'éliminerai à
priori tout de suite euh mais je peux
élaborer là-dessus la suggestion que
vous faisiez que la Cour des comptes
européenne joue le rôle de la Commission
euh car réellement je pense que si nous
devions faire
ça nous euh nous placerons
dans une situation
euh de qui confinerait au contrôle de
l'opportunité ou à l'immiction dans la
gestion en tout cas ce qui est en
principe contraire tant à à notre mandat
qu'à notre statut qu'au qu'
normes généralement applicaes par les
institutions supérieures de de contrôle
et vous êtes bien placé aussi pour les
pour les avoir en tête donc
ça nous n'avons pas porté un avis euh
inabstracto sur les propositions de la
commission mais sur le fait de savoir
dans quelle mesure elle tenait compte de
nos suggestions antérieur alors on avait
fait beaucoup de suggestions donc ça
revient un peu apporter un avis
sur les propositions de la Commission
euh alors je reviens à la au premier
volet de votre
question et nous avons formuler les
choses d'une manière un peu un
peu
c'est pas une lictote mais nous avons
considéré que les propositions allaient
dans la bonne direction parce qu'elle
tenait compte de nos propositions
ou elle tenait compte de nos de nos
analyses et
notamment sur les points que vous avez
mentionné et j'en mentionnerai un autre
d'ailleurs premier point un alors le
mandat le mandat de la commission que la
Commission que le Conseil lui avait
donné c'était quand même un mandat de
euh alors je me souviens un peu il y
avait toute une série de
euh de de de critères il y avait le
critère de la
simplification le critère de la
simplification le critère de la mise en
œuvre de l'efficacité de la mise en
œuvre alors enforcement en anglais et
euh là je rejoins ce que vous avez dit
c'està-dire que jusqu'à présent on peut
pas dire que la mise en œuvre est été
d'une
euh euh dans le cas
d'infraction au critères de de de
Maastricht on peut pas dire que ça a été
d'une d'une violence d'une brutalité
considérable alors il y a beaucoup de
raisons je vais pas revenir là-dessus
euh objective et subjective rapport de
force ce qu'on voudra
euh procédures insuffisantes
ambiguuité des textes large capacité
d'interprétation de la Commission et de
ce point de vue-là nous considérons que
remplissant à la fois le critère de
simplification et le critère de mise en
œuvre le choix d'un
indicateur dominant et objectif à savoir
le l'accroissement des dépenses nettes
euh
et une manière de procéder qui est un
critère vérifiable
or depuis quelques années on on
utilisait alors une série de critères
mais notamment le
critère de
euh du sol structurel
euh alors c'est beaucoup des idées
françaises donc j'aurais scrupule à les
mettre en cause mais à titre personnel
et pour avoir un petit peu vu ces
questions quand j'étais
rucambon j'ai tout en rendant hommage
aux économistes distingués qui ont
défini ses critères qui sont C
scientifiquement tout à fait approprié
présente quand même le gros inconvénient
d'avoir un
caractère alors subjectif et pas le bon
mot mais en tout cas ça n'est pas
vérifiable ça n'est pas vérifiable de
manière aussi objectif que les le
critère des dépenses nettes qui est
quelque chose qui apparaît de manière
tout à fait claire dans l'évolution des
budgets des États-membres bien donc de
ce point de vue-là je crois qu'il y a un
vrai progrès et il y a pratiquement pas
de discussion possible sur ce cet
indicateur alors qu'il y en avait sur la
notion de sol
structurel avec les notions qui vont
avec croissance potentielle en tout le
l'appareil très sophistiqué que les
économistes ont mis au
point pour justifier telle ou telle
position
deuxièmement
cette et donc ça permet à la fois de
répondre à la demande de simplification
et ça permet aussi de répondre
à l'efficacité dans la mise en œuvre
efficacité dans la mise en œuvre euh bah
ça fait partie des propositions
c'est-à-dire que dans le système
actuel le les risques encourus par un
État membre étaient tels que la
Commission et le Conseil dans un deuxème
temps pouvait hésiter fortement et c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait d'ailleurs jusqu'à
présent à prononcer des sanctions à
mettre en cause un étatmembre contenu de
la dureté des des sanctions ah j'ai
oublié
euh alors je sais pas si ça va tenir
mais en tout cas c'est dans le dans le
dans la proposition initiale de la
commission je sais en ce moment c'est un
peu sujet à discussion et et je sais pas
ce qui en ressortira mais on est
également sorti enfin la commission ACC
de a proposé de supprimer cette
obligation qui était faite de diminuer
l'endettement par
20e chaque année ce qui en réalité était
une
mission totalement impossible et
complètement irréaliste alors ça
effectivement je crois que ça ennuie un
peu les états d' frugo et je vois qu'en
ce moment il y a peut-être une évolution
sur ce point mais nous nous considérions
que c'était
une mesure en soi totalement irréaliste
et tellement irréaliste qu'elle n'a
jamais été mise mise en œuvre donc de ce
point de vue là ce qui est prévu dans la
proposition de la Commission comme
sanction
éventuelle
c'est ce sont des choses peut-être moins
violentes peut-être plus étalées dans le
temps avec des délais donnés aux
États-membres un peu plus un peu plus
long avec des plans à 4 ans si j'ai
bonne mémoire pour se mettre des C en
terme de réduction de de la
dette et sortir de du du du cycle année
par année du cycle purement annuel pour
passer à des cycles pluriannuel ce qui
paraît quand même plus raisonnable
et en plus donne une garantie de
stabilité alors évidemment après c'est
un art d'exécution
euh ça nous paraît quand même plus
réaliste par rapport à la situation qui
de de de de actuelle euh autre élément
que je voulais mentionner qui est quand
même aussi au cœur de la proposition qui
nous
paraît très juste c'est
euh l'accent est mis en soi sur la
nécessité de réduire l'endettement
euh c'est pas réduire le déficit en tant
que tel mais réduire le l'endettement et
ce qui effectivement euh
euh paraît là aussi un bon un une une
notion tout à fait acceptable et très
simple à à à comprendre avec la euh la
demande de mettre en place des plans
nationaux et de ce point de vue-là il y
a un effet de euh vous voyez que la la
c'est intéressant parce que ça permet de
voir que euh le ce dont on parlait à
l'instant c'est-à-dire next generation
eu le le le le le le le plan postcovid a
un peu inspiré euh le
euh les travaux dans ce dans ce domaine
de la gouvernance économique en donnant
et ça c'est un autre point important et
c'est un point que nous avions signalé
dans nos rapports précédents en donnant
peut-être plus
euh comment dirais-je d'autonomie enfin
autonomie est pas le bon mot mais plus
de d'appropriation par l'étatmembre mise
en cause de
euh des mesures à mettre en re œuvre à
travers un plan qu'il propose à la à la
Commission et au Conseil euh pour
euh pour réduire son endettement tout
dernier point monsieur le Président si
vous permettez parce que c'était la la
dernière question de de Christine
Lavarde euh se prononcer sur euh sur euh
les les plans et avoir une opinion
objective j'ai dit pourquoi je pensais
que cétait pas à la Cour des comptes
européennes de le faire en plus il
faudrait modifier les TR les traités et
ça c'était un autre critère pas de
modification des traités de ce point de
vue-là la Commission a été assez habile
puisqueeffectivement rien ne rien ne
passe par une modification des traité
dans sa
proposition mais en revanche il y a une
proposition de renforcement du
rôle du
Conseil budgétaire
européen qui est une instance
indépendante d'experti comme il existe
des instances indépendantes et je me
permets de corriger votre question sur
un point Christine euh c'est pas la cour
qui se prononce en France c'est le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques hein on
est bien d'accord c'est pas la même
chose euh donc l'équivalent de cette
instance au niveau européen dans la
proposition de la Commission voit ses
pouvoirs ses moyens surtout renforcés et
ses pouvoirs renforcés et ça ça me
paraît aller dans le sens d'une
meilleure d'une meilleure évaluation de
la pertinence des euh des mesures
proposées par les États-membres alors ce
que fait la Commission le Conseil après
c'est c'est là on rentre dans le domaine
du politique merci Monsieur faudra
essayer d'être un peu plus plus court
parce qu'il y a des autres collègues
qui mais vous étiez obligé oui j'ai bien
compris ça nous a pas échappé Florence
blatrix tu merci monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur Casala pour toutes ces
précisions peut-être pour compléter le
le la la question de collègue quelle est
votre position notamment concernant la
méthode de l'analyse de la soutenabilité
de la dette que certains qualifi un peu
de de boîte noire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots et sur le la
première partie de vos propos
c'est-à-dire la question des erreurs
eu la Cour des comptes française cette
fois a souligné dans son rapport sur
l'impact du du budget européen un retard
de 10
% par rapport aux autres pays de
consommation notamment des fonds de de
cohésion qui intégraent le les crédits
react UE et on a un petit peu ce ce
paradoxe euh parce que bon en tant
qu'élu quand on va rencontrer nos
communes quand on va euh souvent il nous
explique que euh il renonce à demander
des fonds européens euh tellement c'est
complexe pour eux donc finalement est-ce
que c'est c'est pas ces trop grande
complexité un qui
empêche l'accès au fond pour ceux qui en
auraient besoin et qui en même temps
peuvent être la cause de ce taux
d'erreur croissant donc comment que
propose la Cour des comptes européennes
sur ce sujet et par ailleurs la cour
s'inquiète également de deux facteurs à
la hausse des taux d'intérêt qui aggrav
la charge des emprunts et on est
particulièrement concerné en France la
Cour des comptes françaises tire la
sonnette d'alarme également et euh
l'inflation élevée qui risque de faire
fondre euh le pouvoir d'achat du budget
de l'Union donc que propose euh la cour
euh quelle avis donnerait-elle pour
atténuer ses risques je vous
remercie merci euh merci pour ces
questions alors je vais les prendre dans
dans l'ordre inverse commencer par la
dernière
euh sur
euh ce que ce que vous avez dit à propos
alors j'ai pas en tête ce que ce que mes
anciens collègues ont dit précisément
là-dessus c'est vrai qu'en France mais
il y a pas que la France euh il y a
toujours eu des problèmes de capacité
d'absorption des fonds européens que ce
soit les fonds budgétaires classiques ce
qu'on connaissait jusqu'à présent fonds
structurels Fonds de cohésion et cetera
enfin Fonds de cohésion on a pas
tellement mais fonds structurels oui
euh et euh d'autre part plus récemment
donc le la facilité pour la reprise et
la résilience alors
euh c'est pour ça je suis un petit peu
surpris par le chiffre que vous avez
mentionné parce que j'ai je cherchais
désespérément le le le tableau où
j'avais les les capacités d'absorption
euh le taux d'absorption actuel des
fonds de la capacité de résilience je
l'ai pas trouvé mais de mémoire
euh de mémoire alors çaant des
subventions euh on est à
sauerur 33 % d'absorption par rapport à
euh au rythme qui était prévu ce qui est
pas si mal hein c'est quand même la la
2uxè année simplement de de alors il y a
beaucoup de préfinancement encore
là-dedans mais de choses forfaitaires
mais c'est pas si mal c'est un peu ça me
fait penser vous avez dû à l'époque
traiter du plan Junker et on a été très
bon sur le plan Junker on a été les non
seulement les principaux bénéficiaires
mais en plus on en a on en a on a été
pas trop mauvais en terme de
d'absorption sur Next Generation eu et
le la facilité reprise résilience je
crois quand même
que c'est je crois que le taux
d'absorption est plutôt meilleur que ce
qui existe pour les fonds classiques
fonds structurels en
particulier parce parce que précisément
c'est un peu plus simple il y a pas ces
procédures complexes qui existent pour
les Fonds structurels par exemple qui
repose sur le remboursement de coût
éligiblebl où il y a toute une série de
critères à
respecter parfois des nomenclatures
extrêmement complexes qui font
effectivement c'est tout à fait exact et
c'est des constats que nous nous avons
fait très souvent et nous l'avons nous
l'avons nous l'avons
rapporté la complex
des
procédures est un des facteurs
de un des facteurs qui contribuent au
taux d'erreur c'est c'est c'est évident
c'est c'est vrai aussi pour les budgets
nationaux he
d'ailleurs si on prend si on prend je
sais pas moi les les les sujets fiscaux
on trouve le même type de de de de
considération il y a peut-être pas de
fraude mais il y a des erreurs en tout
cas qui sont d à la complexité des
dispositions fiscales bon bah là il y a
des erreurs qui sont dues à la
complexité des dispositions de soutien
des dispositifs de soutien des
procédures de soutien et euh il est tout
à fait et c'est un des facteurs qui
explique la sous-consommation d'une part
par les retards pris dans la
consommation et d'autre part par la
renonciation qui fait que on se retrouve
avec une demande qui est inférieur à ce
qu'on pensait à ce qu'on pensait qu'elle
devait être bon euh et de ce point de
vuel next generation
eu alors ça fait partie de l'évaluation
globale que l'on fera quand on aura
toutes les toutes les tous les éléments
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour l'instant
comme je le disais
euh next generation euu et est plutôt un
facteur de progrès je
crois SAG simplification les fonds ont
pu être mis très rapidement à
disposition beaucoup plus rapidement que
dans le le cas des des des financements
classiques il y a des progrès à faire
nous nous nous efforçons dans nos
travaux d'audit de faire des
propositions de simplification des
recommandations allant dans le sens de
la simplification euh ou dans le sens de
acccroissement des ressources à mettre
au au profit alors je l'ai pas c'était
dans mon propos mais je l'ai pas
mentionné
[Musique]
euh il y a eu des des des évolutions qui
ont été faites notamment avec
l'utilisation de de coût standard pour
certaines dépenses où on considère
d'emblé un cout forfaitaire on se on se
on se casse pas la tête à aller vérifier
toutes les factures mais on dit pour
telle opération c'est normalement tel
montant qui doit être qui doit être qui
doit être payé c'est comme ça que ça se
passe al quelque foois il peut y avoir
un effet d'ben mais en tout cas ça
facilite la la l'absorption des fonds la
dette la souten ité de la
dette vous me direz si j'ai répondu à
votre question sur cet aspect des choses
la sououtenabilité de la dette
et alors là peut-être je recourrais à à
mon à mon collègue juseppé Diana qui est
un grand spécialiste de ça mais ce que
ce que ce que l'on ce que nous disons
dans notre
rapport c'est
qu'effectivement alors on nutilise pas
l'expression zone d'ombre
mais euh on on est assez euh
interrogatif sur la manière dont la
commission
euh sera à même d'évaluer effectivement
la soutenabilité de la dette des
États-membres dans le nouveau dispositif
il y a des choses qui sont assez claires
on connaît on connaît à peu près les les
méthodologies mise en œuvre par la
commission mais il y a quand même des
éléments alors de mémoire ils viennent
pas comme ça il faudrait que jusppé se
se se manifeste qui nous conduisent à
être relativement prudent euh les taux
d'intérêt je les mentionné il y a un
risque alors pour l'instant il est pas
réaliséin on n est pas encore à à
refinancer la la dette européenne avec
avec de l'emprunt mais ça pourra venir
euh et
euh et si on ne trouve pas de ressources
propre euh ou équivalente pour
euh garantir les remboursements à venir
des des quantités considérables emprunté
sur les marchés au titre de de la
facilité enfin au titre de Next gation
new on sera confronté à ce à ce problème
ça c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est réglé
comme du papier musique il y a pas de
tout le monde en est bien conscient mais
pour l'instant personne n'a de solutions
monsieur Diana
peut-être je me proposais de de passer
la parole à à Monsieur Diana monsieur
Diana vous m'entendez oui est-ce que
vous m'entendez aussi très bien
notamment sur la pour pour compléter un
petit peu ce qu'a dit Monsieur Casala
sur la question de de Christine lavard
sur sur la réforme de la gouvernance sur
la réforme de la gouvernance et sur un
certain nombre de dossiers qui ont été
abordés je vous en prie Monsieur plus
spécifiquement je crois sur la technique
utilisée par la commission pour évaluer
la soutenabilité des dettes publiques
alors effectivement c'est une technique
qui est qui est bien rodée donc c'est
pas proprement parler une boîte noire
c'est une technique qui est qui est bien
rée au niveau européen qui est très
comparable à celle qui est utilisée par
les autres grands organismes
internationaux comme le FMI leocde donc
il s'agit cette analyse c'est c'est
relativement simple il s'agit de simuler
l'évolution du ratio d'endettement des
États en utilisant sans V être trop
technique mais la l'équation dynamique
de l'évolution de la dette publique et
en en y appliquant des scénarios
alternatifs concernant les principales
variables qui entrent dans cette
dynamique que ce soit la croissance
économique l'inflation l'évolution
potentielle des taux d'intérêt euh alors
c'est pas la technique en même qui nous
pose problème parce que cette technique
est utilisée pour déterminer le le le le
l'ajustement des dépenses nettes dans
les états c'est plutôt le long terme qui
est utilisé parce que c'est une
technique qui va être utilisé dans la
proposition de la Commission sur un
horizon temporel de 14 à 17 ans et 14 à
17 ans c'est plus de la prévision
économique que ça devient un petit peu
la lecture dans la boule de cristal euh
pour faire simple imaginez que il y a 4
ans nous aurions euh élaboré un plan
pour un pays de l'Union européenne donc
en 2019 euh bon depuis vous connaissez
comme moi les événements qui sont
survenus donc euh effectivement euh
l'analyse qui aurait été faite à
l'époque dans les différents C
alternatifs n'aurait certainement plus
beaucoup de valeur aujourd'hui alors ça
ne veut pas dire que effectivement c'est
un un outil qui est inutile ou qu'il ne
faut pas utiliser mais encore une fois
euh notre problème c'est surtout cette
cette cette durée cet horizon qui est
très long terme et puis dernier point
aussi qui nous incite à la méfiance
concernant cette technique c'est que à
partir du moment où les plans sont
négociés entre les États-membres et la
commission avec un degré de discrétion
important et à notre avis un niveau de
transparence à ce stade qui n'est pas
assez explicite euh il y a le risque
nous que nous mentionnons que bien sûr
les états a tendance à vouloir
peut-être pousser dans le sens de choix
d'hypothèse qui serait un peu plus
acceptable pour eux hein bien entendu si
vous passez d'un taux de croissance de X
à x,1 sur un horizon de 17 % ça peut
modifier de manière
significative la la la la dynamique de
votre dette voilà je m'arrête là
peut-être euh si vous avez des questions
complémentaires je suis à votre
disposition oui y y a-t-il d'autres
questions mes chers
collègues Daniel Daniel grimier
oui merci
président merci à l'ensemble de nos
intervenants moi j'ai plusieurs
questions
concernant la partie énergétique et en
particulier tout ce qui est énergie
renouvelable le le rapport souigne la
difficulté d'atteindre les ob j'avais
prévu venir après Daniel juste après
j'avis préenir parce que on aurait
interrogé
surtout monsieur Stiner SNITER pardon et
Madame bec de lière là-dessus mais on va
y arriver on va y arriver mais sur ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à près
excuse-moi Dani de te couper le sifflet
oui
monsieur permission j'aurais voulu
permission courte alors oui compléter la
première partie de de de ma réponse à
Madame blatrix corto sur le euh sur la
complexité euh ce ce qu'il faut ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que la
complexité c'est aussi la contrepartie
de la volonté de transparence euh et il
y a une espèce de de de tension
permanente qui malheureusement n'est pas
équilibré entre d'une part la volonté de
transparence et de de de de de de
d'éviter soit le gaspillage soit la
fraude et cetera avec des procédures des
procédures qui euh par qui par
conséquent sont très complexes et
euh il faut il faut bah oui si mais euh
il y a une demande des deux côtés donc
euh euh moi je suis très partisan de
simplifier tout ça mais on viendra
ensuite nous dire ah ben vous avez
simplifier tout ça donc ça a favorisé la
fraude et euh et euh c'est pas bien donc
voilà à ce propos juste une petite
question vous nous avez présenté les
chiffres au niveau euh de l'Union
européenne est-ce que vous avez des
chiffres par pays du taux
d'erreur non si vous les avez mais vous
pouvez pas les communiquer pas non non
on fait pas on le on le calcule pas non
non ça on le on le on le fait pas parce
qu'on peut imaginer qu'il y a des pays
où il y a plus d'erreurs que d'autres
faut pas voilà et et vous avez bien
décorrélé l'erreur de la
corruption oui la corruption dans un une
grande exception
mais on sait pertinemment que dans
certains
pays
malheureusement il y a des autoroutes
qui finissent pas des enfin bon j'en
pase c'est des meilleurs c'est très bien
bon là on dépasse le rôle de la de la de
la cour de la Cour des comptes euh j'en
viens donc bon pour Monsieur Dayana il y
a plus d'autres questions précises hein
les collègues donc alors Daniel pour
revenir par rapport à ce que tu disais
tu vas pouvoir rajouter hein
euh moi je vous propose d'en venir
maintenant donc au rapport spécial de la
cour sur les énergies notamment les
énergies marines renouvelables dans
l'Union
européenne un rapport qui fait du bruit
c'est pas mal d'ailleurs pour des pour
des moulins avant en soulevant la
question de l'impact
environnemental des éoliennes qui n'est
pas neutre pour la biodiversité marine
et pour la pêche alors vous savez que
j'y suis très attaché mes chers
collègues et Daniel tu peux tu vas
pouvoir rajouter ton ta question
là-dessus elle s'adresse en particulier
à Monsieur
itaire ou à Madame bec de lièvre et tu
peux rajouter ta question maintenant
Daniel vas-y
peut-être comment oui en m'excusant
d'avoir été un peu trop rapide
euh ma question complémentaire est
simple parce qu'effectivement il y a un
rapport qui met en avant les
risques avec le développement des
énergies marines est-ce que ce rapport
qui qui affirme ses conséquences sur les
impact l'impact environnemental et
notamment la p pêche l'activité de pêche
euh est-ce que il y a une distinction
aujourd'hui entre l'éolien ancré et
l'éolien flottant une remarque
importante par rapport au développement
et notamment au choix que vont faire les
États-membres sur le développement de
l'offshore et puis deuxième
question comment faire cohabiter
effectivement cette ambition cet espace
maritime européen avec à la fois le
développement énergétique renouvelable
et la activité
pêche Monsieur snitire Madame bec deev
je vous passe la parole vous
m'entendez oui bonjour chrisan sit donc
chef de cabinet du membre rapporteur
monsieur monis qui était en charge de
cet audit je suis accompagné par ma
collègue Servin de becc de lièvre qui
était l'auditrice en charge de la France
si vous avez des questions plus
spécifique sur la France on entend pas
bien vous pouvez mettre un peu plus fort
monsieur sitire ou chez nous je sais pas
ah je crois pas pouvoir contrôler le son
je vais essayer de parler plus près du
microphone ouais parler parler plus près
voilà voilà donc euh
le stratégie européenne a été fixée en
2020 d'avoir des énergies marines
renouvelables en croissance très rapide
euh il était prévu une augmentation par
5 d'ici 2030 de la capacité et par 25
d'ici 2050 et cela s'inscrit dans le la
politique de neutralité carbone pour
2050 donc il faut pas oublier cet
objectif très important qui un objectif
énergétique et climatique euh qui reste
l'objectif premier et le rôle de notre
rapport était à la fois de de signaler
l'importance objectif de montrer la
difficulté de l'atteindre parce qu'il
s'agit deun croissance extrêmement
rapide mais aussi de d'attirer
l'attention sur les les risques liés à
cette croissance rapide des risques qui
peuvent être à la fois sur le
l'environnement et sur sur le social sur
la pêche euh donc pour revenir un peu à
la question sur la distinction entre
l'éolien encré l'éolien posé et l'éolien
flottant à pour l'instant il n'existe il
existe surtout de l' lien de posé donc
toutes les études qui existent sont sur
cette
technologie et effectivement il y a des
risques environnemental des des risques
liés collision avec les oiseaux impact
sur les flux migratoires des li risques
liés dans la dans la construction de de
léoli l'éol pososé euh qui fait du bruit
qui peut perturber certaines espèces
donc c'est c'est rqu ont été identifiés
surtout dans la mer du Nord beaucoup
moins dans les autres dans les autres
zones maritimes pour ce qui est du
flottant on est encore à un stade de
développement préliminaire c'est une
technologie qui doit s'implanter
progressivement dans les années qui
viennent et donc il est difficile de
dire actuellement si cette technologie
aura un impact plus fort ou plus faible
sur l'environnement nous avons fait une
recommandation pour augmenter le nombre
d'études scientifiques sur ces sujets
euh et et que la Commission a accepté
donc c'est un domaine à étudier pour ce
qui est de la cohabitation entre les
l'éolien
et la
pêche alors une bonne chose à noter que
les les étatsmembres on mis en place des
plans d'intégration maritime ou de
planification
maritime qui permettent de localiser
différentes activités et de limiter a
priori les impacts d'une activité sur
l'autre
après on peut ne pas empêcher tous les
impacts et pour chaque projet il doit
avoir des études pour voir quels seront
l'impact les impact sur l'environnement
les impacts sur la pêche et c'est au
niveau de chaque projet des mesures de
mitigation de réduction des risques pour
les pêcheurs doivent être prises
euh et ça c'est en train de se mettre en
place dans dans les étatsmembres nous
avons appelé une une étude plus global
parce que quand on imagine une
croissance par 5 ou par 25 comme je je
disaisinttroduction
euh c'est une croissance qui va avoir un
impact majeur sur sur certaines
activités compris la pêche et il
conviendrait de faire une étude
d'envergure pour quantifier ses impacts
et cette étude n'est pas encore n'existe
pas encore c'est pour ça que nous avons
fait une recommandation à la commission
sur ce sujet donc voilà pour répondre au
aux deux questions qui qui ont été
posées je vais vous rendre la parole et
si vous avez d'autres questions je
serais très heureux d'y répondre ma
collègue sVAN peut vous répondre
également sur la France
merci merci beaucoup monsieur SNITER
euh simplement on peut remarquer nous
chers collègues à ma connaissance et je
connais un petit peu quand même en
France il y a pas d'étude d'impact sur
la pêche en préalable à l'installation
d'un parc holienre existe pas moi j'en
connais pas aujourd'hui donc on respecte
pas les règlements européens semble-t-il
voilà et là le président de la la
République a et nous-même nous avons
validé le principe de
l'augmentation je dirais extrêmement
rapide de l'installation d'énergie
nouvelle
renouvelable mais et notamment
d'éolienne sans pour autant réaliser des
études d'impact
sur sur la pêche sur la faune et sur la
flore et et c'est tout à fait
regrettable et c'est on voit bien que
c'est pas en conformité avec le souhait
de la Commission européenne et du
Parlement européen donc ce sera
souligner mes chers collègues est-ce que
vous avez d'autres questions sur ce
sujet à poser à à Monsieur snitire et à
Madame de becc de lière j'avais oublié
le 2 madame debec de lière je je vous
prie de
m'excuser n pas de question mes chers
collègues si si je t'en prie
oui une question sur le justement par
rapport au
rapport du 19 juin la Cour des comptes
sur une possible pénuerie dans les
compos
électrique face au conflit entre la
Chine et les États-Unis et quant aux
objectifs aussi par rapport à la fin des
des voitures thermiques en 2035
donc voilà
quel quel est votre sentiment par
rapport à ça sachant qu'effectivement à
la fois à la fois les composants sont
largement sous la maîtrise chinoise
ainsi que tout ce qui est affinage et
raffinage qui veut répondre à cette
question monsieur monsieur SNITER
peut-être vous êtes compétent en la
matière ou madame de becc de liè je sais
pas alors ça sort du cadre des énergies
renouvelables marin évidemment oui mais
on a v le même problème dans dans ce sur
ce sujet là donc on a aussi dans le
domaine par exemple des des aims
permanents qui sont utilisés dans
lesonienes une grande dépendance à la
Chine je crois que 90 % des éments
permanents viennent de Chine donc on a
le même type d'enjeu dans ce domain
domain là une dépendance très forte
vis-à-vis d'autres pays et ce qui veut
dire qu'il y a un risque géopolitique
lié à à cette activité et qui peut avoir
un impact sur la croissance du
secteur François
tu oui vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est qu'en fait on utilise des TER
rares dans les éoliennes et c'est les
c'est un peu les les mêmes causes
produisant potentiellement les mêmes
effets mais d'ailleurs enfin il me
semble que
on commence à réaliser aujourd'hui que
l'objectif de
2035 semble difficile à atteindre je pas
moi c'est j'en suis moi-même convaincu
mais après on verra il semble que
beaucoup de gens sont de plus en plus
convaincus sur
ce sur le fait que cette échéance est
beaucoup trop proche et en plus on est
en train d'ussi on va pas rentrer dans
le débat politique tout de suite mais de
se rendre compte
que la construction des des voitures
électriques et la livraison des voitures
électriques fait que ça aura un impact
encore plus important sur
l'environnement que de Contin continuer
à à utiliser certaines voitures
thermiques dont les moteurs ont été
enfin ont été étudiés pour pour polluer
moins on va pas rentrer dans le débat
c'est un autre débat
alors il y a y a un sujet qui est qui
est important également c'est le sujet
de la la proposition de création d'un
organe
interinstitutionnel chargé des questions
d'éthique qu'a fait la Commission
européenne lundi d'ailleurs plusieurs
membres de notre commission étaient à
Bruxelles pour en parler avec les
différentes institutions européennes
euh alors Madame Brigitte Cheffer si le
chien nous dit rien
voulez-vous résumer l'analyse de la cour
sur cette proposition s'il vous
plaît merci beaucoup vous m'entendez
très bien ok euh donc euh oui
effectivement la la Commission
européenne a envoyer une nouvelle
proposition ou maintenant c'est la
première fois vraiment une proposition
concrète sur l'établissement d'un
organisme d'éthique interinstitutionnel
euh qui devrait être chargé d'établir
des normes minimales en matière
d'éthique commune à l'ensemble des
institutions euh c'est une proposition
qui date maintenant de
que nous avons recevu juste avant les
vacances d'été les les négociations ont
commencé en septembre à niveau politique
donc il y a il y a il y a des
discussions à deux niveaux il y a des
des réunions niveau politique où chaque
institution envoie un membre de son
institution chez nous c'est monsieur
hizla qui est aussi le président de du
comité d'éthique de la Cour des comptes
euh et en même temps un peu en parallèle
au niveau technique pour vraiment parler
des des déta tail de de cette de cette
proposition donc l'idée il y a eu c'est
un un sujet qui est sur l'ordre du jour
depuis quelques années déjà le le
Parlement européen en 2021 a fait une
résolution en demandant la création d'un
tel d'un tel organisme ah je vois que ma
caméra ne marche pas mais bon peut-être
c'est pas grave euh et le Parlement
européen avait un projet beaucoup plus
ambitieux en demandant que cet organisme
ne
là c'est votre micro madame chaffur qui
ne marche
plus là c'est votre micro allô ça ça va
maintenant ça y est c'est bon ouis
d'accord donc juste un peu pour pour
l'historique donc ça commence il y avait
déjà des des initiatives du Parlement
européen résolution de 2021 où le
Parlement européen a demandé la création
d'un tel organisme interinstitutionnel
mais avec un mandat très très large
aussi pour mener des enquêtes au niveau
des institutions pour proposer des
sanctions peut-être même mettre en œuvre
des sanctions et là sur ce projet
initial il y a eu quand même beaucoup de
réserves notamment de la Cour de justice
euh qui disait qu'il ne pouvait pas
participer mais aussi de la Cour des
comptes euh notamment en vu du fait que
la la Cour des comptes européennes est
l'auditeur externe euh des des autres
institus de l'Union européenne et nous
soumettre à l'autorité euh d'un
organisme composé par des représentants
de des des institutions auditées pour
éventuellement h oui examiner faire des
enquêtes sur le comportement des membres
de notres institutions euh pour
appliquer des sanctions ça c'était une
interférence pour nous pas acceptable
avec les avec le mandat indépendant des
membres de la Cour des comptes il y
avait aussi l'autre souci que la Cour
des Comptes est quand même appelé aussi
à faire des audits en matière d'éthique
et si elle est si elle est partie d'une
un organisme qui vraiment a des
compétences assez larges dans la matière
elle serait mal placée après de examiner
vraiment comment ça se passe dans la
pratique à faire un avis d'audit
indépendant dans ce domaine donc ce
projet initial lancé par le par le
Parlement européen en 2020
n'a pas abouti mais entre-temps là c'est
donc jusque avant l'été la Commission a
a proposé une un nouveau nouvelle
composition ou une nouvelle compétence
pour cet organisme qui sont plus limité
et l'idée maintenant est vraiment que
cet organisme établit des normes
éthiques minimales applicables à
l'ensemble des institutions et d'autres
organismes de de l'Union européenne et
que c'est un comm c'est un un organisme
aussi de de consultation on peut donc se
se rencontrer régulièrement pour parler
des des différentes questions d'éthique
qui se posent que chaque institution une
fois que que les les normes éthiques ou
les standards minimal ont été ont été
adopté par cet organisme par un
consensus donc ça c'est vraiment tout le
monde devrait être d'accord que chaque
institution revoit ses propres règles
l'échange les cas échéants fait un
selfassessment une autre évaluation de
ces règles le soumet à cette commission
ce comité d'éthique euh organisme pardon
organisme d'éthique interinstitutionnel
et euh que
donc par après il y a il y a cetteut aut
évaluation qui bienent qui examiné par
l'ensemble de de cette organisme mais la
proposition de la Commission ne prévoit
aucune aucune un pouvoir sanctionnel
aucune pouvoir d'enquête aussi pour ne
pas maintenant euh ajouter encore encore
des euh des des des organismes d'enquête
dans le domaine on a déjà on a déjà
l'OLAF on a le le le parquet européen
euh donc pour des cas vraiment de fraude
de infraction sérieux il y a déjà plein
de mécanismes et pour les les questions
d'éthique en principe les les
institutions ont aussi leurs organismes
internes qui sont composés par les
membres internes mais aussi externes par
exemple à la Cour des comptes il y a
deux membres internes et un membre
externe dans le comité de thque et euh
donc c'est maintenant la proposition
actuelle donc porte sur cette organisme
qui établit des normes minimales par
consensus donc par accord entre toutes
les les participants cette organisme est
aussi assisté par C experts externes
donc c'est le projet que les les
institutions les participants
choisissent de comm enord ses experts
externes dans la matière mais ne va pas
avoir vraiment de pouvoir nel et de
pouvoir de de sanction euh donc ça
c'était c'était la proposition vraiment
écrite par la Commission et la
commission déjà préparé cette
proposition article par article
maintenant il y a eu une nouvelle
résolution du Parlement européen qui euh
considère que ça ne va pas trop loin et
le Parlement européen donc relance cette
idée de conférer aussi des tâches
d'enquête à cet organisme
interinstitutionnel basé sur des
signalations ou fait par l'institution
même ou même par des lance lanceurs
d'alertes donc ça c'est euh donc dans ce
ce sens la discussion a été reouvert
parce que au début l'idée de la
commission c'était vraiment d'avancer
sur la base de son de sa proposition
réduite et de trouver un accord pour la
fin de l'année maintenant avec cette
nouvelle intervention du Parlement
européen euh je pense il y aura des
discussions un peu plus complexes plus
compliqué et on peut s'attendre à ce que
ça dure encore un peu plus longtemps et
aussi voir dans quelle mesure toutes les
institutions seraient encore euh
disponible vraiment à participer là la
Cour de justice européenne a déjà dit
même sur la base de cette proposition
réduite avec avec des compétences pas
trop élargies la Cour de justice
participerait uniquement en tant
queobservateur tandis que la Cour des
comptes avait bon au moins l'idée de
d'avancer dans les dans les discussions
de voir si on ne peut pas être un membre
euh à tout effet mais on on devra voir
comment comment ça se développe
maintenant suite aux dernières
suggestions du Parlement européen voilà
juste une une première présentation je
suis bien évidment à votre disposition
pour des questions
merci merci beaucoup je vais passer la
parole à notre collègue Didier Marie qui
justement été à Bruxelles lundi
oui merci président euh effectivement
nous avons mené avec le président Rapin
et mon collègue Claude car une mission à
Bruxelles on a rencontré la Commission
le Parlement et et et un certain nombre
d'autres organismes
euh la la la question vous aviez commis
un rapport en 20199 soulignant les les
manques en termes déontologique et de
contrôle de la part des institutions
européennes et et vous appeliez donc à
la mise en œuvre de
solution et et et on soulligne
aujourd'hui la
question de
l'indépendance de cet organisme
or les choix qui sont faits que vous
venez de
rappeler sont de créer un un organe
d'éthique composé de représentants de
chacune des institutions et
assister d'experts qui ne seraient
qu'observateurs d'autre part cet
organisme
n'aurait pas de budget autonome serait
doté de l'ordre de 600000 € pour son
fonction fonctionnement euh aurait deux
ou trois agents et serait hébergé dans
les locaux de la Commission en tant que
tel donc nous nous interrogeons
fortement sur le niveau d'indépendance
de cet organisme et donc je voulais
savoir quelle était la position de la
Cour en tant que telle au regard de ces
préconisations d'origine et des
solutions qui sont proposées aujourd'hui
euh d'autre part euh je voulais avoir
votre avis sur l'opportunité qui serait
donné à cet organe d'éthique de vérifier
et de publier les déclarations d'intérêt
non seulement des membres des
institutions euh mais aussi des
principaux fonctionnaires euh de
contrôler euh les risques de pantouflage
et puis euh enfin euh mais vous l'avez
évoqué revenir sur les délais euh car un
engagement avait été pris de d'installer
ce ce cet organe
d'éthique avant le
renouvellement du Parlement européen or
il semblerait que les discussions s'en
lisent et que ce soit difficile
d'aboutir dans dans ces délais
là madame chaffer
peut-être coucou madame chaffer oui oui
oui oui oui ça ça prend toujours un
moment de ah oui oui d'acc pour que le
téléphone pour que le ça s'active le
microphone oui merci beaucoup pour cette
question euh oui pour la question de
l'indépendance euh donc
euh effectivement cette proposition de
la Commission elle combine elle combine
un peu deux deux modèles de l'un côté
les membres de cet organe organisme
interinstitutionnel ce serait des
représentants des institutions et euh je
pense avoir vraiment un organisme qui ne
comprend pas les membres des
institutions ça serait difficile parce
qu'il faut quand même
que qu'il y a des des gens qui savent
vraiment en quoi consiste le travail en
quoi consiste le rôle les institutions
quels sont les quels sont les besoins
quelle est la la situation des
institutions euh pour pour définir ces
ces règles donc c'est l'idée c'est
vraiment de d'avoir aussi cette
discussion entre les institutions de de
partager les best practices de profiter
des expériences de l'une des autres donc
euh je pense c'est pour ça que
il faut quand même avoir une
représentation des institutions dans cet
organisme de l'autre côté la question de
de l'indépendance aussi d'avoir vraiment
un avis impartiel de quelqu'un de
l'extérieur qui a une une grande
compétence expérience dans la matière
mais qui n'est pas donc vraiment déjà
dans ce monde un peu fermé des
institutions c'est aussi un souci
important donc je pense sur cette base
il aurait cette idée d'avoir cette
organisme des des membres mais que
l'évaluation des des normes est fait sur
la base d'un avis de cinq experts
indépendants et le le Parlement européen
notamment souhaiterait donner plus de de
poids à ces experts indépendants en les
en confiant par exemple des enquêtes à à
ces experts et non aux membres des
institutions et là ser vraiment une
question une discussion politique à ce
niveaul en ce moment en ce qui concerne
la aussi la cette proposition de faire
contrôler les les déclarations d'intérêt
euh au euh cet organisme d'éthique c'est
aussi une des propositions du Parlement
européen ça ne se trouve pas dans la
proposition de la Commission européenne
euh on peut le faire il y a encore
différents modèles qui sont discutés
est-ce que c'est sur base volontaire
est-ce que c'est tout le monde devra le
faire en ce moment l'idée est quand même
de limiter les compétences de cet
organisme sur les membres des
institutions et non sur les
fonctionnaires même par les les
fonctionnaires de haut niveau parce que
pour les fonctionnaires il y a déjà un
cadre réglementaire très élaboré il y a
le le statut des fonctionnaires le
règlement financiers euh donc eu là pour
et puis il y a maintenant je sais pas
combien de fonctionnaires européens il y
en a mais beaucoup de milliers donc
l'idée de cet organe ça c'est vraiment
de se concentrer sur les sur les euh les
questions d'éthique concernant les
membres des institutions où le où le
niveau réglementaire n'est pas vraiment
uniformisé comme c'est le cas pour les
pour les fonctionnaires européens
ou on peut dire qu'il y a peut-être
encore des lacunes dans dans certains
domaines j'espère avoir répondu à votre
questions merci beaucoup madame chaffur
oui oui c'était très très argumenté très
précis alors on a il est déjà 11h moins
le
quart moi j'aimerais qu'on qu'on aborde
la question de la
cybersécurité
monsieur monsieur sobet vous êtes
toujours
là Monsieur sobet oui je je suis
toujours là parfait est-ce que vous
pourriez nous présenter l'avis de la
Cour sur la dernière proposition
législative de la Commission sur la
cybersécurité oui bien sûr d'abord pour
vous dire c'est une proposition donc un
proposition de règlement qui été publié
en avril
2023 réglement sur la
cybersidarité sous l'auspice de Monsieur
Thierry
Breton et nous avons été consultés par
le Parlement européen par le conseil
pour émettre un avis et ce pour une
raison simple c'est que une des bases
juridique une base légale sur lesquel la
proposition de règlement s'appuie
nécessite la consultation et l'avis de
la Cour des
comptes c'est une proposition de
règlement qui est d'apparence assez
modeste en terme budgétaire par parce
que ce sont aussi des mécanismes
volontaires qu'elle propose euh mais qui
pourrai être la base d'un véritable
changement de paradigme en matière de C
cybersécurité qui pour l'instant est un
univers assez fragmenté au niveau
européen chaque étatmembre chaque
organisation privée essaie un peu de
faire de son mieux mais le partage
d'information et la coopération esttant
le ner de la guerre en matière de cyber
défense que ce soit dans la sphère
militaire ou dans la sphère civile dont
on parle euh pour pour ce règlement
euh la Commission a fait une proposition
ambitieuse en essayant d'inciter une
coopération euh transfrontalière
beaucoup plus avancé que ce qu'il
n'existait auparavant le principal il y
a deux mécanismes dont je voudrais vous
parler le premier c'est la création d'un
cyber Bouclier européen qui sera euh un
un réseau transfrontière euh de centres
de sécurité qui euh seront établis dans
chaque état-membre qui souhaiteront
participer à ce bouclier et dont
l'objectif principal ce sera une
capacité beaucoup plus avancée de
détecter les cybermenaces euh de manière
beaucoup plus précoce euh que pour le
moment avec euh on l'espère un partage
d'information entre MT entre étatmemes
qui feront partie de ce bouclier de
manière beaucoup plus automatique
beaucoup plus rapide et donc il va
s'agir de de créer des rapports de
confiance parce que pour l'instant euh
ce genre d'information est partagée avec
beaucoup de précautions beaucoup de
difficultés beaucoup de
délaiis en plus de ce bouclier européen
la proposition propose d'établir un
mécanisme d'urgence dans le domaine de
la cybersécurité et pour faire simple il
s'agira d'une
réserve de prestataires de services
expert dans la cybersécurité qui
pourront être déployés dans les
États-membres qui on feront la demande
en cas d'attaque cyber de grande ampleur
pour pouvoir aider à résoudre le
problème restaurer les serveurs euh euh
résoudre le problème de manière très
rapide donc on parle vraiment d'une
capacité opérationnelle qui pourra être
financée par l'Union et qui pourra être
déployé à la demande des participants
euh à ce
mécanisme euh dans notre avis on on
accueille de manière plutôt plutôt
positive les objectifs euh de ces
règlements on s'interroge toutefois sur
le fait que la Commission n'a pas euh
réalis n'a pas fait réaliser une étude
d'impact euh avec cette proposition et
n'est pas très clair sur le coût de ces
dispositifs euh on connaît un peu le le
montant maximal qu'elle souhaite
dépenser en matière de budget européen
aux alentours de 800 millions d'euros
d'ici l'horizon 2027 mais euh il n'y a
aucune précision qui est donnée au
législateur qui va devoir pourtant
décider assez rapidement d'adopter ou
non cette proposition de de règlement
euh sur exactement combien va coûter ce
cyber bouclier pour les États-membres et
pour l'Union le budget de l'Union et
combien va coûter cette réserve euh tout
ça est encore assez flou donc on insiste
sur le fait que ces estimations
devraient
être transparente afin de permettre au
colégislateurs de prendre une décision
et le deuxième point qu'on a mis en
avant dans notre avis sur cette
proposition de règlement c'est que le
monde de la sécurité en Europe est déjà
extrêmement fragmenté il est déjà extrê
complexe il y a une plor
d'agence
euh de de de programme de projet en
matière de défense en matière civile en
matière de coopération policière
et ce cyber bouclier et cette cyber
réserve s'ajoute un petit peu à cette
complexité sans que le règlement de
notre avis présente de manière très
claire les structures de gouvernance et
de responsabilité donc on incite le
législateur à réfléchir à cette question
question peut-être clarifier le
règlement ou en tout cas euh s'assurer à
travers de propositions d'amendement euh
que ces sujets seront clarifiés avant de
le de dépenser les fonds et de se lancer
dans dans dans dans ce processus euh
pour éviter qu'on ait créé une structure
supplémentaire ou qui euh dans le monde
de l'opération ne permettra pas la
détection plus rapide des menaces et ce
sera un instrument de plus une bonne
tentative mais mais assez héreuse et
c'est je pense pour l'essentiel les deux
points que nous avons évoqué le reste
sont des considérations un peu plus
technique d'amélioration et
clarification du règlement que nous
avons suggéré au législateurs merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup d'avoir été
synthétique avant de terminer Florence
blatrix a quelques questions à poser je
crois oui merci je souhaiterais donc
vous interroger sur le sujet au nom de
ma collègue Catherine main de de sa qui
voilà qui qui a dû nous quitter mal
malheureusement sur ce règlement d'
cyber solidarité donc bon première
question que nous avions euh vous avez
répondu je pense par la négative c'était
c'est-à-dire que vous n'avez pas me
semble-t-il obtenu les informations plus
précis de la commission sur les
estimations de coût et c'est quand même
un un élément important euh vous vous
inquiéterz aussi dans votre rapport de
la structure du financement du cyber
bouclier et qu'est-ce qui explique selon
vous la différence du de taux de
cofinancement européen entre les socs
les plateformes de supervision de
sécurité nationaux et trans-frontières
donc nous interrogeons aussi là-dessus
euh une autre interrogation c'est vrai
que la précédente réforme sur la
cybersécurité sri2 et n nis2 est entrée
en vigueur en décembre dernier et on a
déjà une proposition cyber solidarité
qui mod modifie en instaurant notamment
les socs et les ces donc est-ce qu'il
est à votre avis vraiment utile
d'ajouter un échelon supplémentaire sans
avoir au préalable finalement pris le
temps de savoir si si l'architecture
actuelle fonctionnait euh vous avez
également évoqué dans votre propos le
partage d'information et vous vous
félicitez que celui-ci soit rendu plus
attractif grâce à une incitation
financière mais évidemment au Sénat nous
avons toujours cette interrogation
est-ce que le partage d'information est
souhaitable dans tous les domaines et
nous pensons évidemment à la sécurité de
l'État à la dépense à la Défense
nationale et est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que partager des informations dans
ces secteurs en particulier conduirait à
affaiblir les États et leurs intérêts
fondamentaux et enfin dernière question
vous préconisez que le rapport
post-incident de cybersécurité soit
remis dans un délai déterminé pour être
vraiment utile quel serait ce délai
selon vous et l'ENISA est-elle en mesure
d'y faire face à effectif constant ou
cela nécessitera-t-il de revoir son
organisation je vous remercie merci
Florence pour Catherine monsieur
sobelet oui merci j'espère que vous
m'entendez bien très bien je vais faire
de mon mieux pour répondre à ces
questions dans l'ordre en ce qui
concerne les informations sur les estim
tion de coût euh c'est vrai qu'on s'est
montré assez critique dans notre avis la
réalité c'est que ces estimations
existent mais la Commission a fait le
choix de ne pas les publier parce que
d'un point de vue légal estime que ce ne
sera pas de sa compétence de décider
quels seront exactement les moyens qui
seront mis sur un tel mécanisme et sur
un autre mais plutôt un centre de
compétence qui a été établie à Bucarest
en 2023 qui aura cette compétence et qui
dispose de ses propres infrastructure de
gouvernance on estime néanmoins qu'on ne
peut pas raisonnablement demander au
législateur de de de de disons
d'approuver cette cette proposition de
règlement sans publier au moins ces
estimations même si ça ne restera que
des
estimations en ce qui concerne les
structures de financement entre les socs
nationaux et transfrontières en effet
euh on s'est interroger euh dans notre
avis sur la différence des taux de
cofinancement la commission nous B qu'il
s'agissait simplement de montrer aux
États-membres l'engagement de l'Union
sur ces questions pour que il y ait pour
créer un élan véritablement dans la
création de ces instruments et d'essayer
d'inciter en particulier la la
coopération transfrontière plutôt que de
renforcer les dispositifs nationaux
c'est ce qui expliquerait la différence
des taux de
cofinancement en ce qui concerne votre
troème question
sur l'opportunité de faire cette
proposition de règlement alors que en
effet le règlement d'Inis 2 sur la
cybersécurité ou un niveau élevé commun
cybersécurité a été mise à jour en
2022 c'est vrai que certains des
objectifs des structures mises en place
par la directive Nice 2 et les
propositions de règlement sont assez
similaires c'est pour ça que
notre notre notre avis parle d'un risque
tout de même assez élevé de duplication
néanmoins il faut quand même un peu
modérer ses propos puisque la Nice 2 la
directive qui a été adoptée en 2022
était une mise à jour d'un dispositif
qui existait déjà depuis 2016 qui était
la Nice 1 la première version de la
directive et de nombreux dispositifs qui
sont sanctuarisés dans la LCE 2
existaiit déjà de manière un peu plus
officieuse de manière sous forme de
projet pilote euh donc en terme de
timing je pense que ce qu'il faut avoir
en tête c'est la vulnabilité de l'Union
Europe européenne face aux cyberattaques
les risques d'attaque hybride et le
contexte géopolitique qui peut-être rend
la situation un peu plus urgence qu'elle
ne l'était donc de notre point de vue
euh le timing n'est pas le problème il
faut simplement clarifier la gouvernance
et éviter la duplication des dispositifs
vous m'avez posé la question est-ce que
le partage est souhaitable dans tous les
domaines est-ce que ça
ne ne poserait pas le risque euh
d'affaiblir euh l'Europe ou les
étatsmembres en matière de défense par
exemple je peux tout de suite vous
rassurer le la proposition de règlement
est un dispositif civil il n'est pas lié
à la sphère militaire et bien entendu
les disposition du traité s'applique et
la en matière toute information qui
serait de nature à mettre en péril la
sécurité
nationale ne doit pas être partagé et le
règlement est très clair à ce sujet il
n'y a aucune une obligation de partage
d'information de cette nature avec les
autres États-membres ou avec les
institutions de l'Union les traités sont
très claires sur ce sujet et le le
règlement est parfaitement compatible
avec cette cette obligation en ce qui
concerne notre recommandation sur
l'émission de rapport postincident euh
bon ça n'est pas de notre point de vue à
nous Cours des comptes d'émettre une
proposition très spécifique mais
simplement d'alerter l'attention sur le
fait que il n'y a pas de délai et donc
il faudrait pas que ça arrive 6 mois ou
un an plus tard parce qu'il faut être
très réactif aussi pour apprendre des
incidents euh est-ce que cela peut être
réalisé à effectif constant par l'ENISA
euh sa direction vous dira que non il
faut reconnaître que le il y a de plus
en plus d'incidents de plus en plus de
menaces euh la proposition de
règlement si elle n'impose pas
nécessairement de nouvelle tâches à
l'enissa euh mis à part sur
l'établissement l'élaboration de ses
rapports euh renforce tout de même son
rôle dans de nombreux domaines et donc
ce sera l'autorité budgétaire euh
de de de de d'adresser ce problème mais
mais il est très clair que lesbrinissa a
été très transparente sur le fait que il
y avait besoin de ressources
supplémentaires pour pouvoir assumer ses
nouvelles responsabilités et ce ceci
sera du ressort de l'autorité budgétaire
voilà j'espère avoir répondu à votre
question j'ai fait de mon mieux et je
vous rend parole merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup monsieur sobelet écoutez chers
collègues nous en arrivons à la à la fin
de notre notre audition euh je voudrais
remercier d'abord vous remercier vous
d'être venu ce matin et puis remercier
les gens qui ont bien voulu nous nous
parler de la Cour des comptes
européennes et notamment évidemment
Monsieur François Roger Casala qui était
en présentiel mais aussi madame debec de
lièvre et puis monsieur
di madame Birgit Cheffer et non pas
Brigit Monsieur
Christian et Monsieur Frédéric sobet
merci à vous tous d'avoir participé à
cette réunion ça nous a permis d'être
éclairé sur le le rôle précis de la la
Cour des comptes européennes et merci
pour le travail que vous faites c'est
important merci à
vous très
bien